um i do have to ask you since i have you
here last year you get you have you've
given us some teases about the winds of
winter but last year you dropped the
bomb
that you had a twist that you were
contemplating but you weren't sure if
you were going to go ahead with it
can you tell us if you've decided and if
we'll know what it is when we
when we eventually read it um
i have decided to do that yes i have
decided to do it and
will you know it i don't know um it's
fairly obvious because it's uh something
that involves a couple characters one of
whom is dead in the show but not dead in
the books
so the show can't do this
[Applause]
because they've killed a character that
i have not killed do you know what the
realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video
now before i get started i want to ask
all of you something
i have been considering making reaction
videos to every single episode in the
show but before i went and did something
like that i wanted to make sure
some of you were even interested in
watching those
obviously i have seen the show several
times and even my girlfriend has seen a
lot of the episodes
herself but she doesn't know the show
like we know the show
so i thought it would be kind of fun if
we all watched it together
and helped walk her through everything
so she fully understands it but let me
know what you think
how many of you would watch those videos
if i uploaded them
let me know down below now let's discuss
the new winds of winter and house of the
dragon update from the man himself
george r.r martin as you all know we are
waiting for george r martin to release
his upcoming book the winds of winter
in the song of ice and fire saga this
is a book that he has been writing for
nearly a decade and as of right now
i would say it has to be one of the most
highly anticipated books ever written
now for a number of different reasons
this book has been delayed over and over
again
but lately george has been giving us a
lot of updates which has me very excited
since these updates are happening more
often it leads me to believe he is
almost done
as of yesterday george had to say this
on his not a blog website
it says back to westeros sometimes i do
get the feeling that most of you reading
my messages here
care more about what is happening in
westeros than what is happening
in the united states well i'll be honest
george
i am one of those fans no offense or
anything
but if i want to know what is happening
in america all i have to do is walk out
the front door of my house to find
out the only way i can find out what is
happening next in westeros is if you
release the winds of winter but i
digress
then he goes on to say so let me assure
you that
when not sweating out election returns
or brooding over
other real world problems i have
continued to work on the winds of winter
thank you george no sorry still not done
but i do inch closer it is a big big
book i try not to dwell on that too much
i write a chapter at a time a page at a
time
a sentence at a time a word at a time it
is the only way
and sometimes i rewrite of late
i have been spending a lot of time with
the lannisters
cersei and tyrion in particular i've
also
visited dorne and dropped into old town
a timer 3.
in addition to turning out new chapters
i've been revising some old ones
some of which are very old including yes
some stuff i read at conventions years
ago or even uploaded online as samples
now keep that in mind folks even though
george has already released a lot of
those sample chapters
they will most likely look very
different than how they originally did
like he says next i am constantly moving
things around
combining chapters breaking chapters in
two
and reordering stuff so although we have
seen some chapters already
i don't think they'll be the same when
he officially releases the book
none of this is even remotely new this
is how the first five books were written
i was really on a roll back in june and
july
my progress has continued since then but
more slowly
i suffered a gut punch in early august
that really had me down for a time
and another for different reasons in
early september
but i slogged on and of late i am
picking up steam again
on other fronts well aside from kova 19
slowing down everything we are making
great strides on the upcoming series
house of the dragon
ryan and miguel are in london casting
has begun
it is all looking very exciting alright
my friends
i have said it once and i will say it
again i
honestly believe he is almost done
writing the book
now i know that george has given himself
deadlines before
but those were always so far and few in
between
now it actually does seem like he is
updating us every other week
now maybe this is just me but i don't
think he wants to add
any more stress to his life by upsetting
his fans any more than they already are
maybe i am forcing myself to look at the
glass half full
but i just get the sense that he is
nearly finished with the winds of winter
it sounds like he already has a lot of
the writing done he did mention writing
new chapters in this update
but a lot of what he said had more to do
with revising some of his old chapters
and moving things around or rearranging
some stuff
so i would like to think that he really
can see that finish line
he also said things are looking very
exciting for house of the dragon
and i'm sure that most of you were
already aware that casting has begun for
the show
since ryan and miguel are together in
london i hope that means they are
looking at other actors for some of the
major characters
in this series since this show is still
on schedule to release in a little over
a year
filming will most likely begin very soon
i think this is what has
george so excited about house of the
dragon it's my belief that hbo will be
making some more official announcements
very soon as
well now make sure you subscribe if you
want to stay
up to date with everything unlike some
of the other channels out there
i'll only update you on things that i
believe are official from hbo
or george rr martin himself i'll never
re-upload dvd extras as if they're
trailers for house of the dragon
i would never disrespect my subscribers
or the entire fan base by insulting your
intelligence like that
so don't go anywhere yet my friends
because things are about to get
very interesting as always thanks for
watching the video
i hope you all come back for the next
one have a great day everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you